hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm Kat Alvarado Kat Alvarado and I have
decided to do the try not to laugh
challenge 27 by ADAC the one now several
people I sent this our way not laughing
well we've laughed in other videos we
recorded I think like everyone who does
ease including these challenges we
always fail but it's never like a winner
lose challenge this is like alright we
watch the video alright okay grandma's
penis grandmas me alright let's play
[Music]
so like if you know the solar system
America is like in the middle and
England is like it's a it's the closest
to the sauna thing
so we devised some experience but before
I get to those I think it's important to
understand how much your date actually
works so once you pull the pins as long
as you keep this handle pushed down
you're perfectly safe but as soon as you
let go of the grenade this handle
Springs
[Music]
samuel l.jackson white enemy yes I do
outside man but I start picking up with
the white football players so fat white
and rock stars wear any clothes
I guess about creative how I want we can
only hope to go to sleep
why don't you shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well
out of these are cats like those it
can't
[Music]
[Music]
whoa
the fossil records suggest that in that
gap lies the dawn of humanity
enos homo the hell's going on
Tyron whoa whoa whoa impressive
Paul Walker
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
impart seven essence as Christie I was
LinkedIn
[Music]
two drivers involved in a serious
accident Wichita Kansas the reporter is
talking about the dangerous intersection
when a car pulls in front of a truck
going 55 miles an hour how is that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey Vsauce Michael here and today we are
going to go inside dances autism has
become an epidemic whoa whoa Michael
here about six percent of everything you
say and read and write is [ __ ] what
would you do if there was a child right
in front of you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right wow that one night I think the
other main one that made me burst was
the cat when the cat was just like yeah
that was there's a couple where I was
like it's some pretty funny stuff but I
was able to good team myself yes oh the
Evanescence song that was pretty holy
[ __ ] actually watch it happen have you
seen that video over the zombie popping
up huh yeah ate the one you are the best
at these my friend
I'm so happy you know like when we
started the channel after a wood started
getting some subscribers there was a
point where he was starting a channel
and he and now he has like three hundred
twelve thousand we're at this that was
kind of like seeing you grow as well I'm
proud of you my friend I still don't
know what you look like and I think
you've done videos with your face but I
don't remember subscribe to the real
rejects click that notifications oh hey
cat alvarado comedy on Facebook and
Twitter and Instagram is the cattle
erratum
she's gonna be performing at flappers on
Tuesday night September 5th I'm gonna be
there main room recording our whole bit
and then post sent on the real rejects
and taking all the revenue you get
nothing
cat this is Hollywood shaving back we're
just play fighting men hate Ronnie
chicks become one